that's me
millie ordinary boring millie i
love your dress i think i saw it at
discount bonanza
okay so i was never the most popular
homecomings this weekend
booker is going to be at the dance and
boys never really noticed me
[Applause]
honestly if this was a horror movie i'd
be one of the first ones to get killed
cue the creepy dude in the mask like i
said
but actually it turns out
where am i i didn't get killed oh my god
why do i sound like that
i woke up in the killer's body
the blissfield butcher strikes again
don't freak out you're black i'm gay we
are so dead
it's me it's milly hill hill blissfield
high
feel our glory and our might
and not only is that psycho wearing my
body he's killing it
[Music]
he's like a wolf in sheep's clothing who
knows how many of our friends he's going
to kill are you sure this is safe no
[Music]
oh my god it's a slaughterhouse
i have like less than six hours to swap
back or i'm gonna be stuck in his body
forever
hurry up loser i gotta take a dump i
have to admit it hasn't been all bad
i'm sorry sir i didn't mean interrupt i
move how's that feel
i'll make you wish your stupid face was
never born
oh my god did you just pee yourself
[Applause]
whoa what am i wearing i'm actually
[Music]
great we're gonna get killed by murder
barbie
i can't wait to kill you time to stop
this
[ __ ] we're in this together
i want my body back come and get it
[Music]
look i know i look like the butcher but
it's milly he's crazy okay booker can
you look at me please
dry up [ __ ] will you shut up
you